hello i'm jonathan from the connected
academy talking pictures critical
engagement with visual storytelling is
brought to you in association with the
World Press Photo foundation this week's
conversation is between the Lebanese
photographer Dalia committee and
subjects for her project the missing the
audience perspective is provided by a
filmmaker Benjamin Chesterton additional
historical context is provided by Sri
Makdessi professor of English and
comparative literature at the University
of California Los Angeles so on one
level we have a photographer and
journalist who spent multiple years
making an oral history and visual
document of people who've lost family
members to a war that started 40 years
ago and probably a million miles away
from you are now so I can imagine that
maybe you're thinking what does that got
to do with me well to be honest I don't
I don't really know but maybe if we
think about it slightly differently
there are some jumping-off points for
you to go and discuss in the connected
notes which is kind of the point the
content we provide today is a starting
point for this conversation it's not the
end
thinking in particular about themes like
time evidence vulnerability trust and
responsibility there are three areas I
find fascinating about this interview
one what exactly is it that she's making
to her approach to making it and three
what will it eventually come to me now I
don't have answers for those questions
I've got a few observations and I've got
a few ideas but I don't have answers so
if I describe it slightly differently
then you're about to listen to a female
lebanese photographer who only ever knew
war growing up she became a photo editor
but burnt out through the effects of
looking at an unending stream of images
of war and its effects on her own people
you'll hear how she made peace with
photography again and then when the war
ended in a journalist left their work
done she began to make her body of work
it's a series of portraits of people
like yourself who are left behind each
one in a way I'm thinking of as an
archivist archivists of the scant
belongings of the people who didn't come
back each one provides another testament
for their loved one and the ages of
these people were
- that well one can imagine a time not
far from now when all that will remain
of their stories will be dahlias project
the missing and you have a male English
X radio producer who doesn't speak
Arabic and who has to produce two
different versions of her project for
radio and web audiences over a very
short space of time with all its
inherent difficulties and of course
you're going to hear from the people
whose stories they're both trying to
tell and exactly what that feels like
both then and now don't forget make your
notes in the platform that's where the
value is and don't complain if people
then comment back on your notes if you
don't comment on their they're like
Valentine's cards if you don't send them
don't expect to get them
whatever
my name is Dalia sanuki and I'm a
stalker Farah based in Beirut Lebanon
since 2010 I have been working on the
estimated 17,000 missing and forcibly
disappeared from the 1975 to 1990 eleven
in civil war the victims were from
different political and religious
backgrounds they came from all parts of
Lebanon and they were of all ages the
kidnappers did not just friendship
between men or women at that time but
the missing was not exactly the first
project I did on the aftermath of wars
that I lived in the summer of 2006 I
witnessed the terrible is really
aggression on lebanon as I was working
for The Associated Press in its office
invaded as a photo editor
a year later I went to the south of
Lebanon the area that suffered the most
during the 2064 and it was heavily
bombarded I had seen those images during
the 2006 war but I had not seen them
through my eyes since then that day I
had my camera with me and I entered
homes that were destroyed and abandoned
what really shocked me was how much the
private homes of people had become
public anyone could enter them because
there were no more doors anymore and
obviously no more inhabitants on the
floors lay clothes of those who lived
there
sometimes photograph belongings keys
even though there were no people to
photograph I said that those houses told
the stories of their owners those spaces
reminded me of how much my life turned
into public during the war
I have no personal life back down my
private one would like that as a photo
editor my phone was ranking constantly
starting as early as 5 or 6 a.m.
sometimes 10 hours after midnight my
computer screen was full of messages
from everybody requesting photographs
from all a peep offices like all over
the world
I had to stare at photographs on the
computer screen every day for 34 days
images of the injured the dead the
destruction people crying the death of
their loved ones
heartbreaking photographs of people I
related to the war had forcibly turned
my life from private to a public one the
same as for those spaces
so I took photographs of few houses and
I then formed a series of photographs
that I tried to abandon spaces I only
shot that over a few days but I felt it
was my way of reconciling with
photography after that project I started
working on the Lebanese issues
especially those related to women right
until I decided to start researching the
subject of the missing sari Makdessi
professor of English and comparative
literature at the University of
California Los Angeles the Lebanese
civil war began in 1975 and ended in
1990 it was a war over the distribution
of power among it between different
sectarian groups in the country or
really more specifically the
distribution of power among the elites
of different sectarian groups the
principal axis of tension in the war was
between those who wanted to maintain the
older system of Maronite hegemony the
privileged Maronite Catholic elites and
those who wanted to make the political
system more representative of and
accountable to the population of the
entire country
so although it's often depicted as a
religious war or war over religion or
even a war between religious communities
or sects it really was a struggle over
the distribution of power
despite this fighting and displacement
of population did often blend into
tensions between different sectarian
communities and at times degenerated
into blind inter-communal violence on
top of killed and injured there were
thousands of kidnappings that took place
during the war the kidnappings were
often done on the basis of one's
communal or religious identity because
my beneath identity documents officially
list your religion if you're caught by
the wrong kind of party and you have the
wrong kind of
you could be in trouble and that
happened a lot of people during the war
the kidnappings were sometimes for
ransom
sometimes for murder sometimes for
execution and torture sometimes for
reprisal sometimes revenge and sometimes
her personal vendettas so it's not clear
necessarily why somebody's kidnapped
very often people would disappear and
that would be that nobody would know
what happens to them everybody knows
somebody who was kidnapped I personally
know a neighbor of ours who was
kidnapped and then held for a few days
and then released I have a relative who
was kidnapped and released I think the
same day and one of my closest childhood
friends was kidnapped with his parents
and never heard from again and of course
there's a big difference between killed
and wounded and those who had
disappeared because killed or wounded I
mean awful as that is of course for the
people themselves and for their families
and friends and so forth at least you
know what happened whereas people who
dis disappear you don't know what
happens to them so there's no closure
there's no resolution for the trauma
it's important to point out that those
responsible for the kidnappings of the
most part remain very close to power in
Lebanon given the country's amnesty law
right after the war they've been
absolved of guilt and responsibility and
has never been a kind of inquest or a
sort of Truth and Reconciliation
committee and certainly nobody's been
held accountable for the crimes they
committed during the war so basically
the fates of those that disappeared in
the war has never been resolved
during the war of 2006 many
international photographers and
journalists came to Lebanon to cover the
event the country was full of foreign
press the war lasted for 34 days and the
press was doing a superb work like a
super work covering the direct events
the bombardment tires something I could
have never done when the ceasefire was
agreed on in August 14 the new Jack kept
documenting the direct aftermath for few
weeks before the country was empty again
and the people who were left behind were
left to suffer with their own new
realities that was my case to all the
international photographers had left
they all had them month off to rest but
I was the one who had to stay behind and
the country that was this word was the
one I lived in it was like the horror
never ended this is the same case for
the Civil War and all the wars conflict
trashes that happened since I was born
the media leaves when those ends so
through my photographs I try to tell the
stories of people who are left behind
those whose stories did not specifically
interest the mainstream media the issue
of the missing and kidnapped
haven't been covered much shaky so in my
project I wanted to dig deeper in the
story
[Music]
I met Ida and Leda Jada at the tents
during a gathering for Odette Fallon who
was killed when a car hit her but that
was the mother of two young men and his
sister her son and her daughter were
kidnapped in the 80s the families were
all devastated it was yet another mother
who had died before receiving any
information on the fate of her children
[Music]
the day of ashura has just allowed us to
visit Odette home for a few minutes as I
went from one room to another her home
looked as if it was untouched for
decades inside her daughter's closet
hang a life-sized poster of a male model
on the bottom of the closet next to shoe
boxes lay some old dolls and on the wall
was hanging a black-and-white poster of
the Eagles those are items that people
throw away daily while they have no
value for us they act as one of the main
evidence for the one-time presence of
the missing person the photographs of
the belonging gave much more depth to
the project three years later in 2012
I called Gina to ask her if she and her
mother would allow me to take their
photograph and tell their story
narottama Sofia Ana beholder reserve
vacay
maava que quieres medallion own casita
metal Namas help na la zona Mahajan
Athena maja said no fish evoke asthma
all a muscle massage mode Donna finesse
direct oral the scoop but ma da da la
maman I take a bus wagon what American
Series means
si not know the half a bottle optometry
but no medical norm of the what I Drive
had an ombudsman on hadn't she how to
little barb and it's a house exactly the
Hawara
and because I heartily share this and
extra have him keep the bonnet refer
scoop the decibel was mannequin behind
as the happy third a landlord easements
enemy and the fact as a penny
no hospital Facebook and know let's go
for Williamson a wall cetera with
lollipop bottom little official said
look mama box items of time a new
heroine inductee analytical Jared
colonic robust through my photographs I
try to tell the stories of people who
are left behind those who stories did
not specifically interest the mainstream
media the issue of the missing and
kidnap haven't been covered much shaky
so in my project I wanted to dig deeper
in the story - to learn more about the
different narratives behind the missing
and the kidnapped at the beginning I
photographed for trades for example of
the families then I learned about the
belongings
they kept of the victims with each
family a different story the same pain
of course but a different story and
details after a month or two I got in
touch with Benjamin Chesterton from duck
rabbit
we emailed back and forth and he was
interested in my way of photography
I told him about the project of the
missing and Schumer's later he decided
to come together and work with me on
that project for the BBC for three days
Benjamin and I met mothers of victims of
enforced disappearances
we met with NGO people MP X militia
members women telling about the last
time they saw their children their
husbands they talked about their
continuous struggle and their only wish
to know the fate of their loved ones
mostly indicated with the families were
conducted in their mother tongue and
obviously valya which conducted
interviews and I would assist with
really helping her to shape them in a
sense in that situations its hardest for
her because she's got to bring a
stranger into a situation is very
painful for those women and if you read
the interviews that she conducted with
them all this contact they talked about
each time how the wind is opened up and
that is an extremely difficult thing for
anybody to do repeatedly in front of
journalists or anyone
[Music]
hi does husband command was kidnapped in
1985 along with his nephew Zimmern as
they were coming back from their work
they never heard of them again so along
with a man the mother of my friend I
visited them at home either refused to
be photographed
even after a man interested I looked for
the best place to take the photograph of
Lena there were two chairs that were
placed on each side of a small table and
on the wall behind them a painting was
hanging HIDA brought a framed portrait
of her husband from the 80s and placed
it on the table
along with his fight analyst Nadia so
one below one another man Judith Judith
Kemal
- what the mckameys must've a solid
Caban bajate value in became embedded
noch amol leukemia deduction
prescription written by James Thurber
stubborn
as I move the sofa facing the two teeth
and stood behind it to have more space
in distance Ida's
suddenly sat on the seat and told me to
take the photograph we were all shocked
a man Lena and myself she had resisted
being photographed for over an hour
while we were having tea earlier so I
just clicked two frames and then her
daughter said for the portrait after her
instance what I love about this image is
a huge amount of respect Delhi is not
trying she's not trying too hard and
it's it's subtle and if poetic who
talked about the idea of beauty she does
and it's a beautiful image it took four
minutes
so anyway when I developed the films and
scan them I can't hide a photograph to
the jedis by email both of them thought
that the photograph looked very empty a
man and her daughter on the other side
thought it was beautiful and represented
her situation and the emptiness in her
life i explained by email also that this
was exactly what I was aiming at the
empty chair that was supposed to be
occupied by the husband had she not been
kidnapped instead a photograph of him
from the 80s sitting on the table at
this time Falls for him after he was
kidnapped in the photograph he's smiling
when life was better for the family and
by coincidence he was looking at his
wife Heide
who has aged and was looking at me with
sad eyes thirty years after his
kidnapping hazard in Mumbai in Britain
no Macchio
hiya Tiana's Pacheco surah Baqarah ayah
says Kamala
Jambu Anna are the heck am on the
palpable camera 30 keys and no messages
is no
while the keepers doing me mrs. Murphy
ha
[Music]
kill yourself a day Madonna Mahalo ha
black Subaru okay I don't care the
philosophy of la cama Shimin a dacoit
anneristo Madonna Charlotte now head for
the commence
I know en esta la basura Benadryl and
insular community lawyer fellow
volitional vanilla humans from the
sunless the thurible portray their data
cowlick if if my own people cousin nama
Mikado make a bank in the National
Harlem okay Alexander s Texas sooner I
can measure error but they had a mama
basically other not especially crazy
busy
then we are so worried to me here a lot
to learn Vikram
there's nothing to be tasted there that
is a strength and a defiance and an
anger mixed with a little bit of hope
that each day is getting stuffed out
[Music]
so it's always like a privilege and a
pleasure to be in such a place as a
welcome guest very much as a welcome
guest but professionally you're thinking
what do I need and really that welcome
and that trust it's only worth it for
them if you do a good job if you tell
their story properly it's only worth the
pain that they have to go through when
they open themselves up if you meet that
with a professionalism and a
determination to get it right the
resident waha dirtiest of Austria Nelson
Mandela have weathered Antonius and
Matthew for example epidemiology Matata
Leone is a ridiculous I'm a chimera
among socialism mahadeva has a girl is
absolutely somewhat all of Annie and
these are become merciful you're about
concealer so what is Isabella I believe
that taking the time to get to know
people going back again and again and
again and showing that we care about
them and their problem and that we're
not only here to photograph them and
leave but that we are really trying to
make a change and then their cause has
become ours this makes people open up
and trust us and let us into their life
the family sent the stories of the
missing loved ones they show their
belongings that they had guarded for
decades they share all the scales and
evidence they had collected throughout
the years I had understood the value of
those belongings and photograph them as
precious relics each item alone I was
thinking about what I wanted to say
particularly in relation to you and the
audience looking at a photo and how you
might respond to that firstly and the
thing that I wanted to tell you was that
the danger of a photo is that a whole
someone in time in moment it kind of
says this is this is it right and life
is not like that because it's much more
complex and sometimes we need earlier to
have sat down with the women and just
hear what they think and it kind of
takes away a lot of the formality of
what you're seeing and your feelings
about what you're seeing in fact what I
would say is her interview with the
women in many ways is actually more
humanizing than the photograph itself
and that's something really interesting
to reflect on there is a violence in
photography that on one level perhaps
violence is the wrong word but there's a
tension when a person brings a camera or
a smartphone up to their eye there's
immediately the photographer and the
photographed and there will be the
audience or the viewer as well at some
point and the most powerful stakeholder
in those three-way relationships is
almost never the subject is why this
class interview the setup the way they
are between the photographer our
subjects and the audience is to explore
that tension and then it for us to
reflect on our relationships with the
world we'll bring the camera up to our
eye and make the world our subject and
listen to dahlias conversation one of
the first things that's apparent is that
telling someone else's story is a
speculative endeavor right I mean Dahlia
and Benjamin asked permission of their
subjects in the full knowledge that they
might well and do sometimes say no
Dahlia talk to people agreeing to have
their photographs made years after she
asked and we begin to get a sense of the
negotiation that has to take place
between the subject and the photographer
and the importance of trust in that
relationship I said in the introduction
that what Dolly's work will come to mean
is interesting but that applies to all
our images it's difficult if not
impossible for us to know what our
images will come to mean in future
contexts what their values might be and
to whom which is problematic when we've
negotiated or built a trust relationship
with our subjects I mean what is it that
we promised what is their understanding
and what exactly do they give their
consent for the subject has to agree to
be vulnerable and not just once not just
at the point of the shutter
the photograph may never be seen within
the context it was actually taken the
chances are it will live in many
different contexts even simultaneously
and its meaning might well shift with
each audience in each time the subject
will be vulnerable again the prison
photography blog found a Pete Brooke who
you'll be hearing from in the next
session says we all have a right to
carry a camera but that doesn't mean we
have a right to photograph of the people
now at the time here in session 1 for
you to put down your own moral markers
take a metacognitive view of your
practice think this through
what is your code of ethics make your
notes in the platform join the
conversation in the next session we'll
be hearing from isadora Cass offski and
her subjects Vinnie and Dave Pete Brooke
as I said blog founder of prison
photography is going to be providing
some historical context and one of the
cofounders of everyday Africa Peter
D'Acampo is going to be providing the
audience perspective